round four of the London chess classic  the last stop on the grand chest tour  after 15 draws in a row the best chess  players in the world came in today out  for blood world number one Magnus  Carlsen quickly found himself in a world  of trouble against Frenchman Maxime  Vasily Grob but despite his pawn deficit  the champ managed to defuse the danger  and gain an important draw against his  main rival on the tour us number one  Fabiano Caruana  played some deep opening preparation  against recent world championship  challenger Sergei Kuryakin and despite  the Russians vaunted defensive skills  fabulous Fabi was able to pull off the  events first victory in style yeah I  think you really came down to a good  opening choice white's wasted so much  time the bike has to have some kind of  concrete idea the plastic finally has a  flair leader with a bunch of hungry  wolves giving chase round 5 action live  from London coming up next